hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's place dont wick
manner alright ok this was suggested I
think yamimash played this so I'm gonna
give it a try nothing much to say
besides diving in oh this looks good
piers we start on high go away please
I'm a bit busy it's been all that time
boarding up that door I don't want veget
arts okay so maybe I dove in here for
hiding see I can't jump someone really
wants to get in so let's move huh I
didn't keep him out for long what is
that blood is that my health oh wow well
this isn't this different locale than I
thought it was gonna be I thought it was
gonna be like starting in an open field
going towards a manor I don't know if
I'm already in the manor or what was
that what is that what is that says it's
a statue or something off that's not a
statue I'm gonna
Wow what is happening okay is that a
statue
please tell me that's a statue this is a
statue right yeah it's just a statue
okay
nothing I need to collect right okay all
right we're okay so far so interesting I
mean I obviously don't know the plotter
what a minute wait a minute here
you just hold uh huh it's another one
who's behind me
I was looking okay what do we got here
we got like a key and a gem key and a
gem got both hahaha hi you back the off
man I don't need any of that happening
Mesa can I crouch man oh hello
it's like they're running on
predetermined paths but at the same time
following me okay I got both of them in
my set I think that one turned around
okay I'm quick I won't need to worry
right they don't seem to go that fast
anyway I have half a gem by the looks of
it in the bottom right corner I don't
know what I'm supposed to do hmm don't
know what I'm supposed to do I don't
even know if those things can hurt me
yeah they're definitely coming my way
but I don't know if those things can
hurt me because I was walking right on
top of the other one and it didn't seem
to do anything get out help Oh
my gem a gem disappeared what's going on
here
sorry Stark I got no flashlight or
Lantern or anything oh I see
I collected one gem and it automatically
assimilated into that place maybe I need
to find a red and a purple one oh hello
there's an ominous red glow coming from
under that door I think I'll go right in
oh there it is
hey buddies hello they fell off Oh
coming after me oh no you sons of
[ __ ] I will I will Jack slap you
aha the blue ones in here too eh
hey hold on there but Kirino let me just
grab the blue one blue key oh I see I
opened this door with the red key oh oh
you thought of a bed you said of a bit
I'll bet hey hey good god those things
those things want my niblets right there
grab it grab it grab it grab it
got it I'm out of here where'd they go
hey hey there friend body this little
statue babies let statue babies nothing
to be scared of nothin to worry about
let me get out here how do I get here
thank you
okay now that orb is gonna magically
disappear from my inventory onto the
thingy which it has done and I need to
find the blue door for the purple gem I
don't know kind of a blue glow up here
I don't like those things ah quite easy
to find you are let's go in got out okay
I think I just see it there on the bed
but why is he a miniature statue or not
oh that's a purple key okay something
gonna happen something gonna happen
excuse me while I bugger out of here oh
oh oh that's creepy excuse me
come through okay went into that room
just to get a key and there's a purple
glow okay so the purple is under there
Oh like this something feels very off I
mean nothing is high there's the little
baby's again well I didn't do that I
didn't press the e button all right I
don't have to press any button I just
walk towards it apparently okay so we're
gonna make our way through this while
keeping an eye on you guys so that I can
get to that purple gem and you guys are
not gonna be a-holes I need you to let
me go on my own merry way how do I get
over there seriously how do I get over
there oh wait there was a gap right here
sorry I'm an idiot never mind or what's
her gap hi okay so if I walk right
through you which I'm not gonna do you
gonna hurt me
oh okay they're coming the wrong way
haha he is so stupid
you're pathfinding sucks oh hi huh hi I
could uh oh
where do I go okay go backwards where's
it where's it oh there's the gap uh hi
hi hi friend oh man
like that's top of me where's that damn
gym where's that damn gym
where's the damn job I got it ee ee ee
ee
I got it hi give me keeping an eye on
you
both of you both of you both of you
bully bully bully bull I'm okay I'm okay
okay which way do I go this way and then
I'm out of here
uh-huh Oh what is that oh okay there was
just bookends that looks like a little
cherub babies I think that's what those
are called cherubs aren't they I have no
idea I thought cherubs were supposed to
be nice huh never trust a demonic statue
never trust any statue anywhere at any
time okay so so far so good
all right girl come I three gems what
does it mean congratulations you've
escaped the mansion you're free where
are you
haha that was it really ah man I thought
that was gonna be so much more to that I
mean those little things were creepy but
they weren't exactly terrifying oh well
I mean it was a decent game it was very
well made I don't know what on engine it
was but I mean a lot of custom stuff
custom levels custom all that a lot of
people involved for that game yeah I
guess they were going for a sort of
weeping angels type of Doctor Who thing
which again I don't watch Doctor Who I
just know what they are I guess they
were going for that and man that was a
lot of people working on that okay was
made on Python and I mean it was really
good I liked it but I felt like there
could have been so much more to the game
I mean it was pretty simple going from
straight A to B to V and then getting
out of there so I don't really know
anyway it was alright not that scary
kind of creepy more than anything but
anyway it was still a good game so click
link in the description below give it a
try for yourself maybe there's something
else in the game there were a lot more
doors than what I went in so give it a
try for yourself see if you can find
like an easter egg or something so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that i've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye-bye
Oh God